for the past three months i've shared
with you guys how i've been studying for
my third year medical school exams and
now finally it's time for you to see how
i actually scored in those
i get my
um
hello and welcome i'm zeliha i'm a third
year medical student studying in the uk
and today we're going to find out
whether i'll have to stay in third year
or i'll be able to move forward to
become a fourth year in medical school
now i'll open my medical school exam
results with you guys and i will
actually be reading the examiner's
feedback as well so we'll find out
together what i did well and what i did
terribly wrong i will specifically focus
on my oscar results oscars are basically
clinical or practical exams of medical
school so in my final osce exam we had
four stations so four clinical skills
were asked the first one was pregnant
abj examination and pregnant history
taking and the second one was headache
history taking and the third one was
hip joint examination and the fourth one
was ecg interpretation now i'll go
through what i scored for each clinical
skill and my score in average school and
what was the feedback that i got from
the examiner okay i'll do this on my
laptop i've got my laptop here so let's
see what i got for pregnant after
examination disclaimer this station was
the hardest station for me because i ran
out of time and i didn't have time to
answer the exams questions in the end so
probably this is going to be the worst
one out of all of them but who knows
okay i've got it here
my year three overall oscar results okay
i passed i thought i would pass that's
good my score my overall oscar score is
80.56 and the required standard is 61.36
i pass well over the past mark which is
good now let's look at the obstetric or
pregnancy examination station results
so my score is 68.8 and the pass mark is
62.1
so history feedback just could have been
a bit smoother will come with practice
in time you need to ask previous
delivery pregnancy complications folic
acid and some more obstetric specific
questions yeah fine i don't think i
asked about folic acid so that's fair
enough it's just like so hard to go
through everything so hard to cover
everything because like there's so many
bits and bobs that you have to cover in
the history taking for examination
feedback always wear gloves if examining
patients heart rates and positions and
checking maternal pulse at the same time
too
need to be more confident i think when i
realized that my time was running out i
was kind of getting stressed about it
but i did check the heart rates and
positions you know sometimes this
happens sometimes the examiner like you
got to make sure the examiner sees what
you're doing i did wear gloves to
examine the patient in the end but she
still put that down the examiner did
musculoskeletal or hoop joint
examination results again my score is
93.8 and the pass mark is 62.6 this is
the one that i scored the highest so i'm
very happy about my hip examination for
my communication skills it says
excellence which i'm really happy about
it says friendly and natural feeling
introduction showed empathy early on and
i really liked how you inquired about
impact on daily life at the beginning of
the consultation as this is really
important for musculoskeletal active
listening and responding to what patient
is saying history is excellent if you
see your doctor for anything regularly
was a really nice way of asking about
past medical history covered all major
points slightly within appropriate time
frame so my timing was really good for
this part of the exam my best station
for this exam was definitely hip joint
examination and it shows because i got
all excellent for examination
examination felt slick and well
practiced okay so i'm happy about this
one so i think i felt more confident
going to the station also i had enough
time left in the end so that's why i
probably kinda gave a long some rising
statement because i had quite a long
time until i was gonna run out of time
okay let's move on to ecg so ecg was my
first station i don't know ecg reading
is just very very tricky it's tricky but
i passed
let's see what's the pass mark my score
is 72.2 for this past mic was 61.8 so
yes it's again above the
past mic which i'm happy about the
communication skills procedural skills
clinical reasoning they're all
satisfactory try not to let your nerves
get the better of you if you can once
you relaxed a little your answer flowed
much better i guess i was a bit
anxious during the ecg because it was my
first station like i said so yeah i
guess my nerves kind of was playing up
first clinical examination that was
asked to me was ecg and in the feedback
it says how i was looking very anxious
and once i relaxed a little it flowed a
lot better i could answer the exam a lot
better it said right i think it just
shows that once the exam starts once i
keep going by the end of the exam i feel
a lot more confident i feel less anxious
because like it's actually fine i
realize my last examination during the
exam was hip examination and i scored
the highest for that so it just shows
really the difference between my first
and last exam the first one it says like
be more confident be less anxious on the
feedback but in the last one it says you
were very confident very warm and
everything that i got for the last
clinical skill was all excellent i guess
for me the learning points from here is
try to be more confident and like more
relaxed starting from the first station
because as you go through you realize
that it's actually okay anyway but it's
easy to say but hard to do because we
all know that exam nerves and exam
stress is real my score for headache
station is 87.5
but the past mark is 60 so i'm happy
about it i actually vlogged how i
studied for this exam so if you want to
see that vlog on my channel it is how i
studied for my final exam oski study
vlog and i'll put it somewhere around
here in that video i go through how i
was very anxious about this exam because
this oski was the last exam of the year
and i was just trying to adapt this like
making youtube videos but also being on
top of my uni work which wasn't very
easy so it made it all more stressful so
that's why i'm happy about my results
because it's above the average and i
passed it i think i'm just kind of
worried about fourth year now because
these exams are going to be even harder
in fourth year but i'm happy about it so
that's what matters to be honest i'm
kind of feeling worried about putting
this
on the internet and on youtube because
like all the feedbacks that i got you
know all the mistakes that i did kind of
personal but i just want to keep it real
and i want to show you guys the ups and
downs of medical school so i will put
this
i think i will use this video
in medical school people do not really
share their results unless they're top
of the class and they scored amazing so
that's why i had second thoughts about
whether i should open my resorts in
front of the camera or not so i hope you
found it useful and hope it gave you a
good insight of how the examiners mark
karowski's and what kind of feedback
they give us and so what they do care
about if you did find it helpful and if
you want to see more please consider
subscribing and liking this video and
i'll see you in the next one